[Music]
if you never met a man before what about
your father
I had no brother I was bossy laughs baby
the gods made the Amazon food for peace
to the world
look what I'm going to do oh that's neat
welcome to Johnny Hall London he did
yeah it's not for everybody
[Music]
oops
Cermak maybe not
[Music]
who is this woman
yep that's not gonna work please put the
sword down it doesn't go with the outfit
at all
Wonder Woman rated pg-13 experiences in
IMAX 3d June 2nd
he youtubers is Charlie surprise new
Wonder Woman trailer let's break it down
they totally swapped in a new song
mostly just to hype up the fun of the
movie like she's going to have a lot of
fun kicking all this ass which is pretty
much what she does across the trailer I
love the way they paced it - using this
song it's almost like the drum beats
driving her forward so there's a new
band of the flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video they're
keeping a lot of the same narrative and
some of the clips they're releasing so
Steve Trevor at the beginning the movie
crash lands outside feminists Kyra a
Wonder Woman saves him the Austrians
aren't far behind him and you learned
like he goes up to Hippolyta and tries
to explain what's so terrible that he's
running from and what's getting ready to
happen because the world war 1 this big
conflict the funny thing about the
Amazons though is that as badass as they
are like they're really pissed off that
there's a man on their Island but
they're like hard pass we do not give a
care if man tears itself apart
Wonder Woman being raised her whole life
to be an Amazon thinking about these
great tales of these battles that they
had had learning about their origin
story houses created them to make peace
like she narrates in the trailer sees
all this and wants to help the other
Amazons have already lived through all
this crazy darkside war they're like
hard paths not going to do it man
treated us like crap so why should we
care about them on the flip side of this
though you see Wonder Woman as a young
child learning about this hearing all
these stories seeing the god killer
sword here is Hippolyta tells her about
it and because she didn't live through
any of that she doesn't have any of the
prejudices that the other Amazon's have
but they do have this big battle here on
their Shores it looks like it happens
relatively early in the film when the
Austrians hit the beach they just get
their asses completely handed to them by
the Amazons probably going to be one of
the most fun things ever it's one of the
really easy ways to show you how badass
they are just present them with an
immediate challenge like oh my god we
have all these troops we just have to
get rid of them as fast as possible then
it looks like she steals all her gear
and Steve Trevor takes her to London and
I loved her reaction to pretty much
anything would look like crap next to
Paradise Island it is very literally
created by Zeus to be paradise so she
arrives in London and you hear some of
that voiceover who is this young lady
and we know now that that's David
Thewlis is Ares character just as they
jump through all these fun
culture shock moments where she's trying
to dresses on like trying to kick Eddy
Candy's like oh my god this is amazing
in some of the awkward comedy of her
just trying to walk around and broad
daylight with her sword and shield nope
that's not going to work
they have that funny Diana Prince moment
Princess FMS Keira nope let's just go
with Diana Prince do not tell him
anything about the Amazons and then you
see some of the later battle sequences
like her standing here against the
horizon this is probably the inspiration
for the sunset colored poster that they
released at Comic Con last year just
looks really beautiful one of my
favorite action set-pieces though is her
in this town square just hooking out on
everything
throwing tanks around throwing cars like
it's crazy there's this funny panel from
the injustice comic book where Ares is
like did you just headbutt a tank and
that's kind of what's going on here the
trailers just cut to show you everything
she can do and how much fun she's having
while doing it although totally it sort
of shifts when she walks onto the
battlefield by herself and just starts
deflecting bullets with her shield with
her gauntlets it's like one of those big
moments where she has her true heroes
calling is a peacemaker she's a warrior
that was one of the big things she was
created to be she's amazing at it and
most of the footage is focusing on her
doing that but her true purpose as she
says like the Amazons true purpose is to
make peace bring peace to the world that
is at war right now we still don't see a
lot of areas but we do see some scenes
that are surrounding that final big
action set piece that it looks like he
appears in so it's all that's where
she's jumping over the barbed wire like
big time where she jumps up really high
with the lasso there's this weird thing
that Zack Snyder did with the camera
during Batman V Superman that they might
be replicating a little bit now the
cinematography is very different the way
they colored the film obviously it looks
like there's a lot of color but Zack
Snyder has this thing where he'll slow
the camera down like when you see
Superman punting doomsday across the
camera back in the background it's just
a very different perspective to take
when you're watching someone like
Superman or Wonder Woman go crazy with
their full powers on screen so like all
this craziness it looks like they're
speeding the camera up slowing it down
just making her look that much more
graceful on camera because the cool
thing about Wonder Woman that you see
through a lot of these trailers like
right here is that she trained to be a
warrior for
long time which Superman has not done
he's always going to be the most
powerful member of the Justice League
but what I'm really looking forward to
is Wonder Woman teaching him how to
fight the funny thing about that is that
he doesn't need to be that good of a
fighter depending on who is going up
against even if he's fighting a giant
army all by himself I mean the tactics
for fighting a large group of people are
very different from fighting a single
person but you get a really good example
of what it's like fighting a whole crowd
of people by yourself with Wonder Woman
in this sequence here like you take down
one of their vehicles pick it up and
throw it at the other group of people
and mobilizing as many as possible
causing as much damage in a short amount
of time as possible then you go after
them one by one and pick them off so
we're really not going to see Superman
level villains till we get to Justice
League pretty much everybody besides the
Kryptonians that he's gone up against
has been vastly weaker and has relied
much more on trickery like when he was
fighting Batman so that's part of the
fun of Justice League versus the Wonder
Woman movie because Wonder Woman doesn't
want to kill people even though she's
fighting the central powers she's really
trying to make peace so she's not like
she's trying to kill as many people as
possible but during Justice League there
fighting the parademons so it's like
okay we're going to need to clean house
so it doesn't matter how many of them
they kill so you can just have as much
fun as they want it is going to be
awesome so let me know what do you guys
think about this new footage what do you
think about Wonder Woman so far you
almost can't really tell from this
trailer footage but they've started to
color it the special effects look a
little bit better it's just a function
of them spending more time in
post-production so even though the
footage might be some of the same frames
that you've seen in other trailers
they've actually been changed quite a
bit behind the scenes just to look that
much better
so what's going to happen next is a
whole bunch of flash stuff that's
happening tomorrow they'll probably a
little bit of new footage to hype up the
episode but it seems like they're really
going to reveal savat are in a great
Gustin actually tease what the reveal is
going to feel like on screen he says
it's actually not the same as past
reveals and other seasons I'm
paraphrasing him where the audience kind
of starts to have a feeling first and
then he says it's a more jarring reveal
and it happens kind of suddenly for
everyone at the same time so that's
actually interesting he talking about
the same time probably for the audience
as well as the characters too so I've
already done a couple saboteur videos
I'll link those at the end of this but
they've also revealed a little bit more
about the mother boxes injustice leak
there's some more stuff about the
Aquaman movie so I'll probably be doing
a new Justice League video in the next
day or two I'll try to get it out as
fast as possible I also have some really
cool new stranger things season 2 teaser
so hopefully that will post in the next
couple days too because it has been a
while since we've had some stranger
things so a whole bunch of new DC Marvel
stranger things Netflix stuff coming
while you wait for that you can click
here for brand new flash and you can
click here for a brand new Wonder Woman
thank you so much for watching let's
high-five I'll see you guys tonight
you